[Music]  it's et's social study what the stars  are posting online just like being with  her Blake Shelton can't stop gushing  over girlfriend Gwen Stefani the country  crooner tweeted a pic of Gwen's Harper's  Bazaar feature showing her face on the  Empire State Building  Blake admits he has a lot to live up to  writing thanks a lot how can i top that  I just wanted to do the right thing by  it by Heather lead while Maksim  Chmerkovskiy teases his Dancing with the  Stars return following his calf injury  he posted a pic posing with his partner  Heather Morris that read this Monday  hashtag team maximum Heat then there's  Chris Pratt sharing his secret to  keeping his man boobs dry  they see they see blow driver hits Widow  and Mariah Carey and Nick Cannon reunite  to read their twins a sweet bedtime  story  yeah man I mean it's all about the kid  [Music]  you